مدعوما بالانتصار في مباراته الافتتاحيه
امام عمان سيحاول المنتخب السعودي حسم
تاهله للدوري الثاني من كاس امم اسيا لدى
مواجهه
قرغيزستان بخصوص مباراه الغد اعتقد ان
جميع المبارايات صعبه جدا ومتاكد ان
المباراه الاولى اكثر صعوبه لكن الان
بالنسبه لنا من المهم ان نحاول الفوز
بالمباراه الثانيه لاننا نريد انهاء الوضع
بسرعه كبيره ولهذا السبب علينا ان نلعب
مباراه جيده
للغايه الايطالي روبرتو مانشيني سيكون جل
تركيزه على اصحاب الخبره المتمثلين في علي
البليهي ومحمد كنو وسعود عبد الحميد اضافه
للثلاثي الهجومي سالم الدوسري وصالح
الشهري وفراس البريكان سعيا للانضمام لركب
المتاهلين في المقابل سيخرج لاعب الهلال
ناصر وسري من حسابات مانشيني بسبب الاصابه
حسب تقارير صحفيه ومن المتوقع ان تزحف
جماهير الاخضر صوب ستاد احمد بن علي
المونديالي لدعم الاخضر امام قرغيزستان
املا في الذهاب بعيدا في البطوله التي توج
بلقبها ثلاث مرات من
[تصفيق]
قبل
ه